das ist das fragen lotto naja die roten
sind gemeine fragen die grünen haben
lose ziehen wie viel du willst welchen
du willst du kannst ja zielsicher zu den
roten ja na klar will ich mal gucken was
das ja das gemein bedeutet kann ich ja
immer so oft reißt einfach so auf weiß
in jedem ende abdrehen kann es auf den
boden schmeißen wir nachher zusammen
und wir haben uns echt gedanken gemacht
wie wir dich ärgern können ich hoffe es
klingt ein wenig
lang dauert das denn deshalb ist
jedes album wird bei die anders als das
so vorstellt so seine fans damit nicht
auf eine harte probe ja na klar logisch
also
aber wie langweilig also dass das das
kann man irgendwie machen wenn man jetzt
so brühl ja gerne mag dann gehe ich
irgendwie ein bioladen score ist ok so
oder so ich hab es wollte einfach noch
mal so kay gerät welches sehr gerne mag
dann gehe ich eben im bioladen und kann
mir da immer so dasselbe hoffentlich
weiß auch wirklich dann immer wieder
schmeckt inso und mir nicht doch ich mag
das auch also ich finde es auch toll
also weil ich finde dass ist auch ein
guter käse sogar ja aber bei den
weißweinen ich das selber korea oder
bronze drin ist doch super oder also da
kann man überraschungstüte mehr so ein
stück weit also man hat ja heutzutage
schon schon die möglichkeit vorher auch
mal so reinzuhören und sohn aber
ja ich will eben nicht so dieser ich
habe eben keinen bock so schon voraus
also darum geht es auch gar nicht so es
geht darum dass es mich erstmal kickt so
wenn es mich nicht kriegt denke ich
immer dann kannst du die leute auch
nicht kippen also wir haben auch nicht
so viel mit mir zu tun die kaufen sich
dann album oder kommen auf 12 konzerte
sehen vielleicht noch mal im sommer auf
dem festival damit erstmal wieder weg
aber es gibt ja auch andere die das
wirklich die ganze zeit hören und ich
denke dann manchmal irgendwie das geht
es gar nicht an so bands die sich
wiederholen oder die so denselben sound
fahren also aber ich für mich ist muss
es irgendein grund veränderung geben
damit ich selber gekickt bin und dann
habe ich auch das gefühl dass ich damit
auch wieder leute kicken kann weil es
mich selber begeistert und ja und ich
will irgendwie nicht der alte corinna
käsetheke seien die immer wieder kauft
und immer wieder weiß ach das ist doch
der grün weil dafür gibt es genug rote
fäden bei mir also meine texte und meine
stimme und auch das songwriting ist ja
irgendwie das sind immer popsongs oder
singer songwriter songs und da gibt es
genug rote fäden die sich sogar durch
alle alben durchziehen ich habe in der
anwendung gesagt deutschpop ist es auch
deutschland oder ist es singer
songwriter oder ist das hängst du da gar
nicht in so eine schublade passen ja an
alle oder das ist mir sogar endlich auch
egal ich glaube das ist pop musik die
aber bestimmt nicht nur wenig popmusik
gesagt hätte wäre ich gekämpft waren ist
es so glaube ich schon aber es stimmt
aber ich keine arbeit jedes toppen aber
ich darf das sagen also ich weiß nicht
was es ist also es ist bestimmt hier und
da auf dem fall wirklich filigraner und
schlauer gemacht als eine deutsch rock
platte also guten morgen spinner aber
glaube ich eine rockplatte manchmal
zweites album wobei es da auch momente
gibt die nicht so bei dem album wenn ich
mir das live anhört vorstellen kann das
ziemlich rockig wird ja es wird offenbar
total tanzbar also wir proben es ja
gerade und es ist schon so dass hier und
da auch die e gitarre eine wichtige
rolle spielt als auf dem album aber
es ist trotzdem schon kein deutsch druck
ich weiß nicht ich glaube dass popmusik
okay aber irgendwo da bist du der
einzige musiker der sich gerne mit pop
musiker betätigt aber die beatles sind
auch popmusik es ist doch alles popmusik
ist sind doch alle songs also beat musik
die beatles und ja ok aber jetzt daraus
aber ich sag mal gerade ein künstler in
anführungszeichen der möchte eigentlich
keine popmusik machen weil das ist ja
popularmusik aber ich fand die frage ist
überhaupt nicht böse oder so habe ich so
habe ich so gut war schade oder mehr
hatten wie super oder bin ich abgedrückt
nein ganz wunderbar der akku leer waren
also ja die antwort er ich weiß nicht
ich erkläre mir so gerne mit so dass ich
es auch nochmal versteht also aber ja
das wiederholen ist also ich glaube ich
würde mich echt selber lang war für mich
sind schon jetzt werde ich auch gefehlt
hat geköpft und geteert und gefedert für
mich ist zum beispiel dire straits da
habe ich mich immer gefragt ich weiß das
ist total gemein warum soll man sich
neues album kaufen das ist doch immer
das ist immer genau die gleiche stimme
immer genau erreicht und ich persönlich
ganz persönlich kann die songs kaum
unterscheidet kennen die leute videos
gucken hier daher ist es wahrscheinlich
nicht aber leute da wirst du oft euch
die alben von den dire straits daher bei
musik aber eigentlich hat sich in stuck
und gleich war jetzt mein werde ich
jetzt klar aber ist dass gemeinsam
müssen sie sich jetzt nicht kaufen oder
kauft euch nicht kauft kauft euch die
neue arcade fire oder sowas natürlich
ach so ja
auch mal haben die super koste nicht
viele
familienvater und musiker passt das
eigentlich zusammen
ja das passt gut zusammen im schnitt
aber jetzt wisst auf natur was sagt
deine frau und seine tochter ist es dazu
ja diese die sagen natürlich müssen die
mich auf eine gewisse weise aber die
sind auch schon routiniert und die
wissen die freuen sich vor allen dingen
weil die wissen wenn ich jetzt zum
beispiel über morgen nach hause komme da
bin ich wirklich donnerstag freitag
samstag und auch sonntag okay da fahre
ich dann kurz mal weg aber diese drei
tage bin ich auch komplett zu hause und
bin wirklich da so andere familienväter
so in meinem umfeld da wo ich wohne hier
morgens um 8 uhr ins büro manchmal sogar
früher weil sich druck auf dem kessel
haben und dann kommen sie abends um zehn
wieder ja und ich glaube so im schnitt
sich meine tochter
wirklich mehr als normal arbeitender
mensch das glaube ich und auch
intensiver weil ich wirklich manchmal
ganz lange phasen habe wo ich nur zu
hause bin und ich auch meine arbeit
danach ausrichte die beiden so oft es
geht zu sehen schwierig wird es dann
eben manchmal wirklich wenn man dann mal
im monat decke ist oder so aber das habe
ich jetzt auch in den letzten jahren gut
hingekriegt so manchen nicht immer
höchstens vier tage und dann möchte ich
auch noch mal nach hause ok
hermann grüne beantworten ja aber ja gut
ganz ohne rote ist seht ihr auch
schwierig die grünen auch schwierig mit
einer schönen lobhudeleien ist yamaha
gott nein das kann ich jetzt auch nicht
bejahen oder was ich bin nicht der beste
so und so ja genau das stimmt er sich
schwieriger sich zu rechtfertigen europa
der beste der treff
du fliegst oft in die türkei und bist
mal nach spanien gezogen deine karriere
zu überdenken verlierst du vor probleme
nein das auch weiterhin weit weit weg
geht es ja auch so ein bisschen darum
distanz zu gewinnen und ja aber das also
eine distanz zu gewinnen wie in weit weg
ist was anderes als eine flucht das ist
eine flucht für
fünf minuten oder so ne aber wovon bei
yoga wann ist es nicht ganz so
esoterisch gemeint die yoga nur in dem
song geht es mir eigentlich eher darum
gar nicht jetzt nach tokio oder ist es
das video gedreht worden deswegen lag
das so auf der hand da habe ich gesagt
ja es geht ja eigentlich nicht darum
deswegen darf ist auch tokio seien aber
wo danach weil ich barcelona zu fliehen
und sich dazu verschanzen weil man
irgendwie nicht mehr klarkommt sondern
in dem song geht es darum dass man
seine augen schließt und sich kurz noch
mal sammelt damit man alles das was
gerade um einen herum passiert irgendwie
klarer sehen kann besser verarbeiten
kann da geht es eher so um streit haben
um burnout syndrome um druck oder um
enge räume oder so nur darum deutschland
das ist ja mal wie du bist ja mal nach
spanien um zu überdenken ich bin weg ich
bin aber auf eine flucht oder waren
keine na ja also das stand auch stand
auch wieder in so einer bio die büros
sind die einmal ganz dieses sind ja auch
immer ganz schlau gemacht also dass das
fällt mir jetzt auch noch immer seien
bio steht nicht viel drin wenn ich das
mal so viel schnee ist auch schön
so viel zu sagen du hast noch mal auf
naja wenn ich jetzt hin schreibe mag den
fußballverein eintracht braunschweig
gern da muss ich die ganze zeit wieder
über fußball reden aber du kannst ab 20
uhr ein ding rein machst einfach
braunschweig business doch gefälligst
immer stil laufen und keine ahnung was
ja und am liebsten stehst du morgens um
13 uhr auf oder keine ahnung was da noch
alles tun sicher ja ich bin ich bin nach
spanien nicht geflüchtet sondern ich bin
da hingefahren
weil ich einfach bock drauf hatte das
heißt man also eben spanien valencia
ibiza ibiza valencia sagt kemal ferien
und her hier habe ich über tools geputzt
habe ich da ein paar freunde besucht und
so und das ich dass ich irgendwie dahin
wollte war schon klar dass es perfekt
gepasst hat weil sich gerade mal ne band
aufgelöst hat und ich mal zeit und auch
ein bisschen kohle hatte und ich das so
stemmen konnte das hat ganz gut gepasst
aber da hat man natürlich dann die
möglichkeit sich einfach wirklich mal
ganz in ruhe so mal runterfahren und
neuen plan machen sich neu aufstellen
ist natürlich toll wenn man so ein
bisschen
salz wasser noch um sich rum hat gut
okay aber das ist so ein bisschen dein
motto auch distanz gewinnen zu dem
problem indem man eben mal die augen
verschließt für eine kurze zeit oder
hier wo ich meine grüne ist locker das
ist eine grüne jacke wurde
aber eben mal um block laufen und block
laufen ist immer gut
gerade wenn man eine unterhalten neues
ein wartesaal ist denn sich total
stimmig wie hast du das hinbekommen ja
ich glaube das ist immer so eine
mischung aus
house aus dem lied was man so zu haus
geschrieben hat und aus und aus dem text
und jetzt kommt aber an der springende
punkt
das liegt auch ganz so einen typ mit dem
ich zusammenarbeite und an den
mitmusikern die dann später dazugekommen
zb
peter licht polarkreis sagt sehen genau
ich wollte sagen der usa nach der
polarkreis 18 kommt nicht die neue aber
die davor um heil allein und so das hat
er allein allein ja genau und das auch
schon zweiter hand was ich mit dem was
ich mit liebe gemacht habe wir haben
irgendwie nie haben wir so ein draht wir
beide sind grundverschieden auch
grundverschiedene musiker
aber trotzdem ist es so dass wir so das
mögen was der andere macht uns tierisch
befruchten
und total reiben und immer streiten und
aber es kommt was ja warum man es kommt
immer was da rum und ich glaube dass so
ein album führt liegt am ende eigentlich
vor allen dingen dem typen weil er dann
noch mal ran geht an das was ich mache
also dass ich das ist dann so der typ
mit dem ich mich austauschen also ich
bin die ganze zeit immer nur
einzelgänger ich mit niemandem ich mache
gar nichts aber irgendwann wenn das
alles fertig ist die songs geschrieben
die texte geschrieben dann geht es dahin
zugucken wie will ich das musikalisch
machen und dafür ist der typ total
wichtig also da hat er einfach so und
deswegen hast du doch recht so nett zu
dir zu der frage davon mit dem pop und
so da ist dann glaube ich auch so es ist
schon eine sehr schlaue art von pop
musik fans popmusik ist weil der typ der
einfach auch so gut ist also der hat das
ist schon ziemlich hat viel style
vernichtet ganz ganz gute finger
sehr schön noch eine zum schluss würde
ich sagen rot oder grün
nicht so lang weil wir den einen guten
sachen das war doch schlecht rot-rot ist
gemeint
geht nicht ab doch genommen hat
du stehst du dir und deinen fehlern
welche sind das genau
also ich bin schon sehr ungeduldig
fehler nummer eins tierisch nervig für
mein komplettes umfeld ich bin
ich weiß nicht ob es ein fehler ist aber
ich bin sehr genau und ich kann mir
alles merken
ja das nervt du hast vorhin gesagt dass
du einer bist du ja ja das nervig
ansonsten glaube ich dass ich
das ich sonst gar nicht so ultra viele
andere fehler habe da keine vorwürfe die
im streit vor
du bist so wir streiten uns nicht
ehrlich
ich
habe mir nie so nicht
also ja ich glaube schon dass ich so
manchmal so ein bisschen zu genau in dem
einmal so ein bisschen so zu spießig
oder so es kann also auch mit dem alter
aber
viele sachen sich echt entspannt und
locker so viel fehler habe ich nicht ich
jetzt hier so sagen könnte was ist noch
etwas mehr fehler die du hier nicht
sagen kannst ja sicherlich also ein paar
sagen kann man nicht sagen also ich kann
jetzt auch nicht so genau sagen was ich
mit meiner frau streiten weil sie schon
mal da bin ich beruhigt vorsichtiger
harmonische beziehung geht ja um ein
unter dem ski club aber so weiß ich
nicht was das gibt's ja noch so viele
fehler
ich habe total o beine ist sie doch
geritten als gehen ja nie ist glaube ich
ein genetischer fehler oder weil sie
nicht fußball spielen das führt zu der
fan von pierre littbarski okay aber ich
hab so ein bisschen platt bereits zum
senkt füße noch nicht okay du musst
vielleicht bald man immer miteinander
einher ich weiß ist ja glaub ich hab ich
habe alle drei haben den super jackpot
gewonnen über und sonst
darum steht dann in einer bio du stehst
du deinen fehlern wenn du nichts zu
erzählen hat ach so ja
da das dass das war glaube ich so das
thema ach ich bio war das denn schon
wieder ich meine sehr geehrten dem
inzwischen bekam noch eine andere ja ich
habe mich entschieden ich fand ich auch
nicht schlecht die zweite aber
ich glaube ein fehler so also mir wurde
ja zum beispiel zu dem ersten beim
ersten box ein wurde mir so angekreidet
hellmann das ist dieser total im
lustigen posterboy von dieser pop band
aus braunschweig hatte er vor bosse
schon mal eben mit 17 und das wurde mir
immer so als fehler so
naja ok das war mein fehler sechs sätzen
so ne und für mich war es aber nie ein
fehler so und für mich war das also die
haben immer so getan als würde ich mich
davor verstecken dass ich mal eine band
gespielt habt somit 17 aber für mich war
das so der große stadt glaubt dass meint
so diese bio gut dass ich dass ich dann
das ist für mich überhaupt total dazu
gehört und das war die das war die
goldene zeit in meinem leben weil da
ging das alles so los dann musst du
diese frage jetzt doch noch beantwort
die schließt sich nahtlos an diese
ausführung an früher kraftvoller rock
mit genau hat scheint jetzt auf
schmusekurs verkauft sich das besser
naja guckt mich an jetzt verkauft sich
nicht besser werden verkauft wie diverse
also ich weiß gar nicht
ich glaube er hat sich ich weiß nicht
die zahlen kenne ich nicht mehr ich
kenne ja meine zahlen immer so ganz gut
auch ein fehler sein dass so ein
bisschen zahlen geben also ich meine
zahlen ich guck mir ganz ahlen an
ergebnisse zahlen super nervig weil ich
eigentlich seine mucke machen aber
manchmal bin ich dann schon das kommt so
die selbstständigkeit wenn ich schon so
ein typ geworden das muss ich abstellen
das ist mein fehler den ich so gut zu
wissen aber wenn man schlechte zahlen
hat dann weiß man dass man die vorlagen
kann ja ja so eine wichtige aber es gibt
eben auch leute hier sind daran schon
kaputt gegangen weil die dann eben bei
den amazon charts alle 500 gucken müssen
doch welche klasse war ein ganz großer
fehler weil diese amazon charts das ist
eigentlich ein buch weil wir haben ja
auch ein bogen youtube buch was da jetzt
schon vorbestellt werden kann und das
ist mal da mal da mal da mal da mal
damals dass er dadurch dagegen weil wenn
man hinten ist jede bestellung wird sich
daran macht ist ja das stimmt das ist
total bescheuert und das hat auch
irgendwas mit 1000 anhänger generieren
glaub ich wenn ich schwester bestellt
gehst du mein buch wahrscheinlich
wirklich 30.000
hektar irgendwohin gut machst du dir ein
sehr gutes gefühl du kannst du mal
selber bestellen ja wieder in die top 10
tausend aber was soll die frage noch mal
auf das wehrlose kurs naja also tage auf
sich nicht besser java vorgänger also
auch schmusekurs sehr schöne grund 40
durchweg beleidige al arabija
ja ich muss sie ist auch nicht so gut
verkaufen
ich glaube ich glaube das was ich
wirklich am ende
das was am ende leute berührt ist glaube
ich immer eine ehrlichkeit das muss auch
nicht immer so schmutzig sein und so und
das was heimatstadt offenbar hatte weil
das war echt ein grund ehrliche sache
ich will nicht ich will jetzt gar nicht
dagegen an reden das ist eine ungute
sache war ich finde ich irgendwie auch
also würde ich jetzt auch wenn ich so
eine band heute sehen wir die richtigen
menschen menschen menschen junge ist
aber dann würde ich auch sagen na gut
der ist jetzt irgendwo so alt wie kim
frank damals als damit echt angefangen
hat und
wenn man da so in die falschen kanäle
gerät und den falschen sourcing dann
geht's schnell bergab weil er ist mit
der meinungsbildung ist es eben noch
schwierig mit 15 16 17
da hat man noch viel zu lernen einfach
und das ist ja auch toll trotzdem ich
wohl zukunft wie war der anteil frauen
oder jungs mädchen bei halbzeit und
leser jetzt hochinteressant weil
also sowieso das publikum hat sich
einfach geändert ich kann das
heimatstadt publikum kann gar nicht
beschreiben weil wir auch nie eine
eigene tour gespielt haben oder so die
haben sehr viel festivals gespielt und
vor allem so viele radiofestivals und da
kann man das publikum gar nicht so
richtig fassen weil er ist also von der
familie bis zur oma bis zum studenten
ist und auch alles da aber
das was ich heute geändert hat ist
glaube ich schon dass man ein publikum
der schnitt bei wegen konzerten wir
haben das letzte bisschen guckt ist so
von 25 original bis 65 weil so
radiosender in berlins und radioeins
hören wirklich leute die auch ein
bisschen älter sind aber gut
musikgeschmack haben und bei seinem
kurzen konzert hast du das eben genauso
also dass eben der vater der ist also
lehrer und der sohn der studierte lehrer
und die beiden sind zusammen da und
gucken sich das andere finden es gut und
50 50 ist es zwischen männern und frauen
nicht
erwartet ich habe festgestellt dass ist
ein typisches männer album dein album
also oder nicht männer album weil die
texte sind so gut männer hören ja keine
texte und ich denke immer bei guter text
guter texter texttafeln und dann wenn
ich aber dass den studien wenn ich wenn
es vorbei ist noch mal was wo wann wie
weit war deswegen habe ich mir extra die
texte nummer schicken na ja verstehen
wenn männer können ja die texte
irgendwie mit den texten nicht teuer und
das ist so typisches text alm wo man die
texte ebenso gut sind dass man sie sich
nicht merken kann er verstehe aber
frauen das ist ja glauben aber ich habe
schon also die emotionalsten reaktion
auf meine texte kommt wirklich von
männern scheiße ist das war zum
bleistift also die sind dann so
aber ich liebe euch eine menge mails und
so das sind oft typen also was wir hier
alter ich will jetzt irgendwie ich
glaube ich mache meine braut ein
heiratsantrag und so und das hat jetzt
nicht so wenig auch mit deinem song xy
zu tun und vielen dank nochmal und du
hast mir so ein bisschen emotion hat die
augen geöffnet und sogar und erzählt
dass also das sind dann oft die männer
die sich da plötzlich öffnen aber auch
natürlich dann wahrscheinlich an der
falschen adresse
trotzdem wünsche dir dass du noch viele
männer eröffnet
dank wir kick